complétez de cyril hanouna qui est ici
on se rencontrait émission sur m6 vers
22 heures et quelques le principe est
simple des gens qui se connaissent
virtuellement sur les réseaux décide de
franchir le pas et souvent ça fait des
rencontres assez surprenant surprenant
c'est encore c'est un petit mot
surprenant qu'on voit c'est le réclament
on a regardé tous les épisodes version
se rencontrer sur m6 avec des candidats
qui avait conquis l'an facile
[Musique]
je m'attendais à voir une voiture de
luxe et à ses goûts ses attaques au
convoi
n'est pas choisi en même temps il faut
dire que certaines candidats n'y allait
pas de main morte sur les retouches
photo charles ou pas
un
truc on a pas que c'est moi tu trouves
bas je trouve que ça ressemble à changer
pas les lunettes j'ai pages et plus même
neigé pas la même bouche à une mission
avec des petits mensonges mais surtout
de belles histoires d'amour
c'est la fin de ma vie
on va faire des petits bobos
s'est terminée avec chelsea on a fait la
connaissance de jérôme qui est tombé
sous le charme d'une brésilienne avec
qui pouvait passer des heures à discuter
donc je suis père tard juste pour
discuter puisque la nuit avec al qaïda
rencontrés pour de vrai il avait plus
grand chose à lui dire mais fiennes il
fait bon aujourd'hui je fais ch
aujourd'hui
j'ai peur que tout est traîtresse
mais rassurez vous on s'est rendu compte
que le coût d'une expression ça marche
plutôt pas mal au final
[Musique]
alors ça fonctionne correctement 2 14%
parts de marché c'est pas mal en saison
une puissante mille 12% saison 2 donc ça
se maintient sa perd un peu quand même
attendre alors la note de 3 à francesca
et franchement je suis très très sympa
que c'est vraiment parce que c'est
l'émission préférée les patrons à moi je
serais vous aurez une autre note mais
moi ça passe des bons choix oui m'enfin
j'en profite qu ils soient pas là pour
dire que c'est complètement pas si je
regarde la barre assez génial
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
notre démission c'est une émission qui
sent le faut voilà de a à z j'ai
l'impression que les gens qui viennent
les candidats qui viennent sont des
candidats qui n'ont pas réussi à aller
dans des émissions de télé réalité pour
tel ou tel régime et qui du coup se sont
fait ce sont refoulés là se sont fait
refouler là et c 'est de s'inventer une
life essais il n'y a pas de
positionnement on est entre l'émission
de dating entre l'émission télé réalité
à prendre a confié avec des gens qui se
parlent ça sert à quoi m6 est fou c'est
que voilà ça fait six mois qu'ils se
parlent sur les réseaux wi litres en
cause ils ont rien à se dire connaissant
pas la route mal à la wii magali berlin
vous adorez bouter cause les attendait
mais caméra au moins
[Musique]
dix noms la vérité c'est que engraisser
moderne déjà dans des teams moderne oui
c'est moderne parce que les gens c'est
la vérité il se rend compte sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est vrai que santander
c'est la vérité et s'est adaptée pour
une fois que c'est un dating adaptée à
notre temps
ce sera fait sous toit c'est très bien
et en plus de ça je trouve ça drôle
rigolo je trouve ça émouvant parce que
c'est il ya des histoires font
sympathique et ça montre aussi que des
fois l'airé les réseaux sociaux ça peut
leur faut ne pas parfois ça peut ne pas
être la vraie vie et l'espoir peut être
aussi la vraie vie
jb un petit set 2007 pareil je trouve
que c'est une émission qui est vraiment
dans l'air du temps et en plus voilà
c'est une virtuelle ils se rencontrent
c'est dans l'air du temps
[Musique]
vous savez qu'il se rend compte dans
l'émission
s'est nourri ces derniers temps pour moi
c'est vraiment là mais seront compensés
dans des missions
c'est donc la rencontre des deux des
deux protagonistes
et quand il se rend compte franchement
on se demande ce qu'ils connaissent un
petit peu 10 secondes ne fait pas du
tout alors voir antoine c'est un bon bon
bon rouge à regarder j'aurais bien avec
lui une belle et vraie histoire d'amour
et j'ai l'impression qu'il a envie de la
même chose je m'attendais à voir une
voiture de luxe et à ses goûts ses
attaques au convoi quand viendra le
temps oui ça soit à l'époque je faisais
toujours
le visage c'est pas du tout pareil son
corps ne tient pas du tout je veux pas
le 29 frustré il lui dire la vérité un
pas aussi forte et flasque être ça
pardon je suis un génie c'est mort
lowe's d'urso se trouvait pour le sport
sombre ces sucreries
oh
tu vas banide avait près du pont avec le
confinement l'association tu me trouves
sais pas ce soir
[Applaudissements]
en même temps le toit ne sait quand même
pas brad pitt non plus willy denzey du
pauvre il est grand
il est franc et
demi de francs et béni oui oui mais il y
peu d'humour je ne peux pas citer
qu'elles notent maintenant moi alors je
serai là en septembre il me l'a dit
cyril semi 2 1 alors alors alors ça ne
vous dit pas que c'est dans l'air du
temps et que
non c'est un kinder filmé quoi c'est un
truc moi ça ne me fait pas c'est pas une
émission qui me fait rêver après c'est
une émission week et moderne ça tu as
tout à fait raison mais c'est pas une
émission qui plaît particulièrement
quand je trouve que c'est c'est plat il
ya il se passe rien en fait la mise à
sac
des fois effet dans la chambre il m'a
bien sûr
d'un gros problème avec le arrive à
franchir mais enfin je trouve qu'il est
grand temps que vous marier pour vous
des coureurs oui on vous dit quoi faire
bondir
sup et
l'ena mais d'un peut poser dur
[Applaudissements]
sur le clézio calamars hier ah ouais bah
oui bon courage pour la nuit dont salord
ni combien à une très bonne amie à moi
je serai pas dans septembre
elle n'est pas prévue inquiète
je le sais ça moi je men on peut le 08
11 fric et pourquoi je donne raison à
francesca oui solidarité et cornaque
c'est de la télé réalité à l'envers
c'est à moitié réalité et tu les vois
c'est des pros en la voie menant et
habitués à les voir tout le temps donc
c'est une série qui va durer ils ont des
assurances grande part est grand mais
renvoie encore les voir mais là tout est
faux ça se sent et en plus c'est une
émission en fait cette émission tu
commences à avoir un couple il faut
attendre quinze minutes pour voir un
autre morceau après faut attendre encore
trente minutes pour avoir un autre
morceau
c'est vrai que c'est pour moi c'est très
ventée c'est très trop monté
forcément la cible mais quand bien et
puis chasse à la cible c'est des gens
qui des gens
qui me fait beaucoup rire et pour le
coup on a tous fait c'est les fameux
filtre demande émane liberia
se fait donc entassé des vidéos et des
papillons qui sont au même
titre vous moi je
mais j'avais filtre
bel-abbes la beauté ordinale ne ce
filtre pas
compte que c'est faux abbas a en tous
les cas les fonds que c'est vrai qu'il
est arrivé enfin un versement regardez
les images fait que là en fait tu penses
que tu trouves tu as acheté ne non non
non soyez patients dieu que le monsieur
qui l'a achetée à ferrari et c'est une
skoda qui arrive bien
hahaha
pendant le show
voilà sa voix elle rita ça fait bizarre
de pas maintenant ça fait bizarre je
m'étais imaginé julien au wasabi
kardashian c'est vrai que je me sens un
peu gêné ça a plus rien q c'est par la
fig des photos qui me plaît et si je te
paie aussi mais tout est parfait
voilà voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
musique vous me dit on n'attaque pas le
physique voilà où l'avait dit la
surprise alors il faut que la personne
au naturel est très jolie oui elle est
violente sur les allées mieux filtrer
les différents essais comme le café
quand une fille trop mal
non non non non franchement oui mais
c'est pas pour étouffer avec votre voix
de ce côté ci on aimerait bien faire
venir s'il vous plaît on lève le doigt
alors mesdames messieurs
mais on est dehors alors moi je rejoins
d'être au calme en ce que francesca est
tenu et d'ailleurs je lis pas aussi on
dit malheureusement toutes les personnes
nommées en septembre les personnes qui
auraient aimé l'émission ont très mal
vendu l'émission et ont vendu justement
ce qu'on voit c'est à dire de la grosse
daube malheureusement
je mets simples parce que moi je mets
aussi être là en septembre et voilà
cyril ça c'est pas toi baba mais cette
émission c'est vraiment la culture du
vide et c'est la culture de la gênante
extrême moi ça me pèse non mais moi ça
me met mal à l'aise quand il n'a plus
repris du [ __ ] c'est chaud yole alors
on a eu à chaque fois les gens n'ont
jamais sur le papier des grappes bender
et vous c'est quand on regarde les
jeunes en chaire éléments sans nom mais
moi j'ai pas envie de le voir enfin la
wii mais ça n'aurait vu les événements
je n'ai pas envie de le voir visiblement
il ya 400 millions de téléspectateurs
qui regardaient en dernier qui sont
comme moi et je pense que l'année
prochaine quand on va atteindre les 500
milles ça va s'arrêter parce que essieux
se rencontraient on va boire un café ont
d'abord quelque chose on se met pas à la
télé tous ceux qui sont là est la raison
francesco ce sont les recalés de la télé
réalité que s'ils veulent bien sûr faire
des placements de produits et/ou
services viennent vraiment après être
reçue dans tpm paix parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils vont être le buzz de la semaine
mais à aucun moment
rapide l'homme
c'est une des meilleures télévision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le but est donc aujourd'hui à paris à
remous dans les
numéros il ne sait rien faire ses
besoins combien ça fait mal mais moi je
tombe à aller 6 l e3 non